foreign
Microsoft Excel is the simplest yet an
important skill required by ID employees
Excel improves the data management
effectively and escalates the
productivity exponentially the simple
spreadsheet software is now an integral
part of most business organizations
across the world msxl is used for
various needs and requirements of
business organizations in fact a few use
Excel for tracking sales Trends and
generate valuable insights from the
business data the simple interface helps
users to easily understand the software
and perform basic activities in this
excel fill course we will be learning
the topics from the advanced Excel
section but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our Channel and
don't forget to hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply run one
of the major advantages of Ms Excel is
its flexibility feature this feature
allows users to define the structure of
information they need to manage with
ease Excel is so simple to use that even
a completely new user can manage to
implement a few functionalities in Excel
for complicated tasks the user needs to
undergo training and gain hands-on
experience to use it in a better manner
even after three decades Ms Excel is
still the most preferred and used
spreadsheet software around the world
access updated features help users to
connect to a variety of data sources and
import data the data collected can be
cleansed modified and prepared using
Advanced Excel features the fine-tuned
data can be run through formulas and
necessary insights of the data can be
extracted not just this users can also
visualize the data reports making Excel
one of the most powerful business
intelligence tools the Visual Basic
support from Excel will allow users to
customize and generate interactive
business reports and dashboards anyhow
the top uses of MSX and are as follows
Ms Excel is commonly used for financial
related activities the reason for its
popularity is that the user can Define
custom formulas and calculate quarterly
half yearly and annual reports for the
sales and marketing Community Excel
helps to effectively keep track of the
sales leads project status reports and
invoice reports Microsoft Excel is also
very popular among professionals from
data science background as it allows
them to easily work with statistical
formulas and graphing the finance
department makes use of Ms Excel for
payroll expenses tax calculations leave
reports timesheets and employee
performance analysis another important
use of Ms Excel for any industry is
forecasting this helps organizations in
Revenue projections cost projections and
manage their supply chain effectively
now let us go through the salaries of
data oriented jobs that require Ms Excel
the average salaries of data oriented
jobs we with excellent requirements is
anywhere between 5 lakhs per annum to 10
lakhs per annum based on experience and
job roles and responsibilities having
the introduction and applications of
excel discussed now we will go through
the agenda for today's session we will
start off by discussing external basic
knowledge where we will go through the
fundamentals of excel followed by that
we will start with learning how to lock
or protect cells in Excel followed by
that we will learn the print plate setup
in Excel next we have goal seeking Excel
charts in Excel and then we will go
through data validation in Excel
followed by that we will go through the
lookup functions so there are basically
three types of lookup functions which
are vlookup Edge lookup and X lookup
followed by that we will learn slicers
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel budget template then we
will understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel then we will Dive In
into Excel macros and visual basics for
beginners then we will learn regression
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel power query then the
perfect tables in Excel and finally to
make things interesting we will go
through the most frequently Asked Excel
based interview questions and answers so
I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with the
advanced Excel tutorial
what is Microsoft Excel so Microsoft
Excel is a software product designed and
developed by Microsoft storing data in
an organized way that is rows and
columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that
Microsoft Excel is also used to extract
the insights from the data and represent
it in the form of visually appealing
graphs and charts now we have a basic
understanding or an overview of what a
Microsoft Excel software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page
so this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel home page where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the Practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert draw paste layout formulas data
review View and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using Microsoft Excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select sum or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas Theta review View and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that I have
selected the Home Tool here so when I
press on the Home Tool this is the
ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further a more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups so when you see in the
previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the phone bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and I think you can see a small Arrow
option over here so this Arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular Arrow Mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when I clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session and
now moving forward we have cell and
address so when you open a Microsoft
Excel sheet you can find boxes so each
and every box is named as a cell and
each cell has its own address for
example the highlighted cell over here
has an address B3 so B is the column
name and three is the room name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in a company
has employee ID name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using Microsoft
Excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
through the Practical demo first so I
have started my Microsoft Excel and this
is how the home page of Microsoft Excel
looks like so you have a blank workbook
over here if you want to create a new
workbook you can select new Option so
Excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
Excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming show list small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that Excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses Channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice your name Excel has got it so
Excel will provide you with some variety
of options based on your requirement now
for this session let's get started with
a blank workbook which looks something
like this since this tutorial is based
on the fundamentals we'll go with the
blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw paste layout
formulas data review View and help so
this is the toolbar and under the
toolbar I have selected home and you can
see this is the particular ribbon what
we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to home page and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some FX to
the text font size and font style etc
etc apart from this we have also
discussed about the cells in every sheet
so this particular cell has an address
so you can see the address over here
which is B3 so B happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name now we also had a discussion
about the share tracker right now we
just have one sheet if you want multiple
sheets you can just feel free to select
on the plus option which will always
create you some extra sheets and you can
navigate through sheets just by pressing
on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with hundred percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with Microsoft Excel now that we
know the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employees
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
let's type in employee details
yeah we have the cell now an employee
details table will have the information
related to employees so the information
will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and let's take another one which is
phone number
yeah
so so far so good
and you can see that we have some
problem with this particular column the
designation and the name the name of the
designation is practically good but it
is not visible so when you uh when
you're not on that particular cell you
can see that the name is incomplete over
here so you can always fix that you can
just you know manually change the size
of the row or cell or you can also feel
free to you know double click on that
cell which will automatically you know
set the size of that particular cell and
same goes to the blood group just let's
try to double click on that and same
goes to phone number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and we have an option of merging
them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names Joe
John
uh Mary mark
Susan
and then
Jennifer
let's open mic
let's open them
chef
Jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
foreign
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose uh Joe to be the CEO of the
company
and John as the software developer
and Mary as tester
Mark and finance
Susan also in finance
and Jennifer in testing
and Mike in marketing
same goes for Tim
and again Jeffrey into software
development
and uh
Morgan into testing again
now let's click on a c so that it gets
you know resized according to the length
of the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
[Music]
and nineteen thousand dollars let's
increase the salary of a CEO so let's
keep it one lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
thank you
here we have the blood groups now let's
type in the mobile numbers
[Music]
foreign
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or remove a column so let's
imagine that we wanted to add a serial
number as well but somehow we forgot to
add it now you can always add a new row
or column for example here we wanted to
add a new column so we just have to
right click on a select the insert
option
here we have a new row now
let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from one to ten
that's how you do it and apart from this
you can also uh you know change the font
of the entire row you can change the
font to
say
aroni and you can always also change the
font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be better
and you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen now let's save this
so I'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your Excel
file with some basic data
and to learn more don't forget to get
subscribed to Simply learns YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to stay updated so you are the
first person to get an update on any
technology not just Excel now we are on
the Microsoft Excel and this particular
spreadsheet is related to employee
details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current salary and
name of the employee serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can lock the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to log the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I
and now let's right click and go into
format cells and in the protection
option make sure that you uncheck the
locked icon now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge to
self find we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the log option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get added and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
unblock cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 1 2 3 again now select OK and
now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully logged and
protected all the cells in Excel now let
us verify that the cells you wanted to
protect are really protected and locked
or not so we have unlocked phone number
and designation and everything else is
locked now let me try and edit the blood
group so when I double click or try to
edit this particular sheet then I'll be
receiving a warning from Excel it says
the cell or chart you're trying to
change is on a protected sheet to make a
change unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there's a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and the software developer happens to
become the senior software developer and
the tester as well let us imagine that
he will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
foreign
setup in Ms Excel
so to understand the pitch setup in Ms
Excel we will go through a demo
inventory in Excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with the Practical demo
we are on the X
is the data I was talking about the
restaurant data where we have the First
Column that is Rank and next we have the
restaurant name followed by that we have
the sales happening through that
restaurant and then we have the segment
category that is what kind of service
does that particular restaurant offers
now this is the list what we made and
what if we wanted to represent this data
and form of a printed paper right so I
guess you can see all the columns and
rows here so you can see that we have
almost like 250 rows so there is no
chance or there is no way to print all
those 250 rows in one page of course it
is practically possible but when you try
to read the content it'll be so tough to
read Because all the rows will be
clubbed together so closely so that you
cannot read it so you need to print them
Page by page so and you need to also
take care of the data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what page setup basically
means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how page setup is
possible in Ms Excel so to go to the
page setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print option
and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here
and you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is Ctrl
p so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method so the second method is
you can see the toolbar over here right
which has file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help so the second method we can use
page layout option from the toolbar
and you can see when you click on the
page option from the toolbar you have a
new ribbon over here so this ribbon is
all about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options are menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup now let us
look at the third method so the third
method is something similar you have
view option on the toolbar so just
select a view and you can see we have
few page setup options over here as well
the normal page break page layout custom
views and we have gridlines formula bar
heading zoom in zoom out select to zoom
free certain panes right so all these
are also the page setup options so we
have the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar
earlier with those now let's get started
with the Practical mode on page setup
for that let me use the simplest method
that is holding the control key and
pressing P which navigates me to the
print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and Note 1 for Windows you
can see this option is the printers
option for example if you are connected
to a printer which is the hardware
printer then your Ms Excel will show the
printers name here so other than printer
you can also make some other
arrangements where you can just directly
print your complete data in the form of
PDF and then you can export your PDF to
your recipient that's also possible okay
now let's get started with the first
option that is print active pages okay
to understand this better we need to
create a new sheet not a problem so you
can see that we just have one sheet over
here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet
or let's rename it as
restaurant
sheet 2.
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so I'll use the
shortest method that is holding the Ctrl
key and press P now you can see that
here we have six pages in total from the
active sheets so the current active
sheet is the top 250 sheet so this
particular sheet is the current active
sheet so if we print the entire data in
this particular sheet then we will end
up printing six pages now let us select
the other option where you have to print
the entire workbook
right so now you can see that there's a
change in the number that is 12 pages so
what is a workbook so basically workbook
is the collection of entire sheets and
your Excel home page so in this
particular Excel homepage you have the
first sheet that is top 250 and the
second sheet that is the restaurant
sheet 2 right so the combination of
these two sheets make up a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item so if you
want to do this then let's get back here
now what if your customer or what if
your client wanted the top 10
restaurants only so you can select the
top 10 restaurants
foreign
doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see Excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncolluted one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers present here and what does
collected mean anyway so this is a
question right now the answer for this
question will be a little similar to
your examination Hall okay let us
imagine that you are an examination Hall
and you are the invisilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students okay so you have
your question paper distributed into
three sheets that is you have marked
questions and your questions are fit
into three papers right in this scenario
we have 250 rows and all the data is
split into six sheets that is sheet 1 or
page 1 page two page 3 page four right
now if we wanted to print 10 copies then
the arrangement of papers will be page 1
page 2 page three page 4 page five page
six in continuous order right that is
collated if you wanted 10 copies of
different different ways where you
wanted to print the first sheet first
then you wanted to print the second
sheet second and the third sheet third
that is you'll have 10 copies of first
page 10 copies of second page 10 copies
of third page and so on that particular
approach is called uncolated approach
and if you are printing the pages in
continuous order for 10 times then that
particular approach is called as
correlated approach so this is what we
had to learn about collated and
uncommuted now let's get back to the
third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there is something wrong
select all the elements Ctrl V yeah now
we have our data pack now we have the
third option that is the portrait
orientation okay so when we click that
we have two options that is portrait and
landscape so you might be having a good
idea like when you try to click a
picture in your phone we have two modes
as well that is portrait mode and the
landscape mode so when you click on the
portrait mode this is how your data will
be looking now to understand the
difference let's click the landscape
mode so when you click the landscape
mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
keep the page orientation as portrait
orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and A4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select the page types you want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is afo A5 A3 Etc but here
we just have two that is A4 and letter
so basically you will get those options
and followed by that next we have
margins so here you can see we don't
have any margins for our data okay so
now we can add some margins by setting
up this one as an option like last
custom setting or you can also choose
normal wide narrow right so your page
will be changed according to your margin
size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now we can also modify that you can fit
and print these sizes so you can
remember the first option that I said of
printing all the 250 rows in one single
sheet this is how you can fit it so fit
the sheet on one page where you can see
all the 250 rows are fit into one page
but the data is not readable so but we
don't want this type of an approach
right so let's keep it as the default
one which is no scaling so these are the
variety of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the PDF format and mail
it to your client you can also do that I
think I have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the six pages and into PDF
format and then you can mail them to
your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to two three and any number of
copies you want for now I'll keep it as
one copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here you go here we have the restaurant
data in the form of PDF
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the PDF format
now we are back on the home page now we
had some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select that as well
you need a new file
PDF
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant to
PDF data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option now when you see
into the print option we have limited
number of page setup options over here
now let's check out what we missed so we
are in the page layout here so we had
gone through the margins we had set all
the margins and then we have also gone
through the portrait and landscape now
you can see this size when we were in
the print menu option we had only A4 and
letter but here you can see there are a
wide variety of options that is other
than later we have tabloid legal
statement executive A3 right we have A5
and many more other options and if you
want some more paper options you can go
to more and you can always select few
more options that's how you do it and
yeah we didn't had the break option so
remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal A4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the brick option
so what does break option does right you
can actually break the page remember we
spoke about the top 10 things or the top
10 rows you can always do that so you
can just keep the top 10 restaurants in
your first page and then break the
remaining and to set page breaks you can
select the cell now I need the top 10 so
I'll select this particular cell which
is in the 11th position
and now I'll try to implement the page
trick insert a page trick and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of a page
break implemented onto your page now how
do you see it you can see it by
selecting Ctrl P where you can see the
first top 10 restaurants being printed
on your sheet so there you go we have
the first top 10 restaurants printed on
our sheets so that's how you use the
page break
now let's try to eliminate all the page
tricks so you can select next and reset
all page tricks so the page break has
been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just if you
want you can add a picture to your
background I think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well
let us select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the text files and
then you can change the color so that
the text becomes a little visible
yeah that's how you do it now if you
don't want the image to be added on your
file you can also remove that delete
piece background and there you go all
the images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles
now for that let's select the print
titles option
now let's select the rows to repeat on
top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
being added to all the sheets you can
see the page 2 page 3 page 4 page 5 and
page six so you can see the title is
added to all the sheets
so that's I use the print titles option
so now we are on the Excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular Excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names role
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like maths science computer
statistics social GK and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right so let us imagine that a company
has come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student who watches Mike right so for
Mike to attend the interview he needs 75
percentage or above so uh he can make
some modifications in one of these
subjects right so there is always an
exam after the exam called as
Improvement exam so if you can like this
course and extra marks in the subjects
which you have scored less so that you
can make up to the percentage what
you're expecting you can do that so here
in this particular sheet uh Mike has six
subjects right and in such subjects you
can see he has code 76 91 45 71 94 and
62. so out of these he have scored less
and one subject compared to all the
subjects one subject is really low that
is computers so what if he can give an
improvement exam and increase his
percentage to 75 right so that can be
done so if we can do some Brute Force
methods like we can change the marks
like 55 and then check this particular
one so it's getting 74 right so using
the brute force method will be a little
bit lengthy so you can do this because
it is just a small table which has least
number of data and you just have one
single cell to modify so that can be
done in small tables but what if you had
some table with hundreds of rows or
thousands of rows that will be time
consuming right so for that we have some
inbuilt functionality in Excel that is
called goal seek in Excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65. now we need
the target as 75 okay so let's write it
as
Mike's Target right we need mic so mics
new Target as
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation so here on the toolbar which
has file home insert Etc we have one
other option called as data so when you
click on data from toolbar you'll have
this ribbon and in this ribbon we have
various options so when you come into
forecast group we have an option called
what if analysis when you click on
what-if analysis you will have a set of
options out of which we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is M9 so we need the value 75
here right so what is the cell that you
need to change here for that you need to
select this one and select this
particular cell here right and now you
can select ok now you can see that Excel
has automatically run all the
permutations and combinations and has
come up with a number so that the
overall percentage of mic will be 75
percent right so the expected marks that
Mike should be getting in his computers
Improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
Target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in Excel now
let's quickly get on to the Practical
mode where we will have some data sets
over which we will be trying to apply
the charts now there are various types
of charts in W and those are the pie
chart the column chart the bar chart
column versus line pivot chart and
sparkline charts so we will discuss one
after the other first let us discuss
about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the Tuple bar and inside the toolbar you
can see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option and
when you select the insert option you
will have a ribbon here and inside the
ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimension pie charts donor type of
charts
Etc right so I would like to go with the
three dimensional pie chart as it looks
a little more appealing and easy to
understand and now there you go this is
the title of the chart and these are the
legends of the chart and this is the
chart area and these are the values now
we can uh you know kind of add the
data and labels as well so you can just
have to press the plus icon over here
and you'll have the options you can add
the data labels which will give you a
lot more interesting values
and uh you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and let's imagine that you wanted
to show the information related to this
particular one which is a Volvo which
has the biggest share so this is in
front right now now what if you wanted
to show the information related to Tata
which is over here right for that you
can select this particular Arrow key and
you can just twist it and there you go
it is coming in front this will be a
great way of presenting your data to
your clients right
yeah and there is another option where
you can directly explore this like you
can pick it out you can say this right
Point explosion where you can split it
out and you can show that especially
like you can highlight it and show it so
that's the you know a great way of
presenting your data so that's how you
can work with part